[Music]
there's a difference between being a
drag queen and being transgender 3 2 1
Rockets well over here fast enough there
are two completely separate things you
know one's like artistic expression and
one's an actual like gender identity
yeah like the easiest way I had someone
explain it to me it was like drag is
what you do trans is who you are I'm
clarifying for the people out there
because me and the type of drag the odd
you maybe not with my rainbow hair right
now y'all but when I have my blond hair
and my cleavage shot and I look like a
woman whether that is a transgender
woman or a cisgender women I get hit up
by men in the public who don't know drag
and they do think I'm a woman or they
don't understand the difference even
when I tell them so I do think it is
important to know that there are people
out there who don't know the difference
and for them I would just really say
this is an illusion of pretend of
performance that is an identity and
there are people who like to walk the
line between both and that's fine too
my family is supportive of my career 3 I
was just saying it didn't start off that
way
I started drag a year and some change
ago and I didn't post anything on
Facebook or anything like that until
about three months in because I was
afraid of it and then my brother who
it's the one that I kind of argued with
a lot was the first person actually
share like my pictures and look like
keep it going and like I'm proud of you
and everything and then from there all
of my family followed suit probably
because they think I'm gonna get rich
from it and they want money but well at
the age of 17 I got thrown out of my
house by my mother on my birthday when
they found out I was gay and ever since
then they haven't supported me up to
this day yeah it's very hurtful I'm
gonna change my answer to somewhat just
agree after hearing your story I
remember when I first moved to LA and
started getting gigs that like seemed
really impressive to me I was like dad
do you know what drag is I do drag and
he was like no no and he was like well
don't tell your mom because my mom was
really sick and then my mom passed away
and I never told her and so that's
something that I think about a lot women
can do drag this is an issue I've always
been very divided on and I have to be
very careful with how I say this I do
stand divided on what my definition of
drag is and like we're a biological
sister woman fits into that because
obviously yes women can do drag because
we have a drag king here you know and
like we have femme Queens and hyper
Queens so yes they can and they do do I
personally agree with that I know too
many girls who have come up to me and
asked me to teach them drag and I get
them honor to show at my home bar or
whatever and they show up and just like
their regular Club makeup in their club
outfit oh my girl that is not I have to
jump off of that really quick like my
belief is that drag is the art form of
gender it is the performing of gender
and we are all negatively impacted by
societal expectations of gender how we
should or shouldn't sound like what we
should or shouldn't wear what we should
or shouldn't be into and so we all have
something to share through drag so to
tell anyone that their drag is not valid
is is really frustrating because we all
have struggles with gender and the thing
I will say as as the as assist woman is
that like as women we are taught our
entire life you know to listen to what
men tell us about how we're supposed to
look and the whole point of drag is to
throw all of that in the garbage
I was very feminized as a child and
getting really personal here but I'm
actually a cancer survivor and I lost my
hair and was bald when I was a 7 year
old girl and so everyone around me
in order in the name of supporting and
loving me which is beautiful try to make
sure to emphasize everything that was
feminine about me and for me my drag
persona and discovering drag and doing
drag has been all about reclaiming Who I
am and my identity it's your opinion and
how to argue about the opinions that's
your bit live your fantasy but and my
head is telling someone I'm gonna
impersonate you and I'm gonna live out
what I think you are but you can't tell
me that just think and that's what I'm
saying like I'm on the disagree side I'm
on the somewhat agree side because I'm
saying if you don't do it and that goes
for everybody really do it don't be in
there half acident sometimes people
don't know how to do it everyone has a
right to look the way they they and I
have a right to stand on this line no
you're good stay over there but we still
gonna disagree with it you can stay on
the cloud all you Walter drag reinforces
negative stereotypes about women 3 2 1 I
chose disagree strong like strongly
disagree because it said drag and I
don't think all drag is female
impersonation I fully agree with that
the only reason I'm here at somewhat
disagree not over there is because there
are a lot of drags standards that
reinforce female stereotypes such as
like nails lashes wigs and there are
some amazing super queer performance
entertainers that are somewhere in this
room that are just amazing and do
whatever the [ __ ] they want but there
are queens who will go to the club and
they'll read you because they're like
roll you're not wearing nails girl your
heel is not above five inches and by
reinforcing those stereotypes for a drag
queen impersonating a woman you're
reinforcing those stereotypes on the
women that you think should look like
that I think a lot of the really
unreasonable expectations from drag
queens about the nails and the hair and
the hips and the bat is because suddenly
drag queens are on television and one of
the unfortunate parts about breaking
drag to straight people or straight
audiences is making it to some degree
palatable and the reason someone like
rule
all shot to fame was because she was
stunning she was beautiful she was a
supermodel I think we're definitely
seeing the effects of stunningly
beautiful drag queens on television
because now a lot of us are expected to
look that way and like but in fairness
you could wear whatever you want yeah
you know I'm here because I love the
beauty of a woman the way she looks
whether if she's skinny big girls or any
of color it's the beauty of the homage
that you're you're giving the problem is
not that the Queens and the performers
who want to look like a beautiful woman
it's the Queens who will judge other
Queens for not doing that for not
following these female beauty standards
the drag community is diverse and
inclusive
three-two-one saying y'all I mean I'm
gonna have 200 make your shift make your
shift thank you I'm really gonna have to
say somewhat disagree even from my own
stance on an opinion question earlier
where I didn't believe that necessarily
all cisgender women should do drag drag
is not 100% inclusive because I have
been told I'm not this enough or I'm not
that enough I had a girl touch my
stomach and go oh girl don't you want to
wear Uyghur at all and I said no I don't
so I mean I can't say that we're totally
inclusive I think we're going towards
that and we should be but we're not
right now and dragged at large is still
such a boys club I know as a king
there's either people don't book Kings
at all or there's like a quota but
they're like oh like we're gonna book a
king and it's like no [ __ ] I'm talented
like it is in your best interest to book
me and if you don't book me I'm gonna
produce my own show which is what I did
yeah I feel like there are definitely
pockets of inclusivity and while I do
love West Hollywood I will say I didn't
start getting booked in West Hollywood
until I was on a TV show right cuz they
wouldn't have me there and it still
feels weird sometimes going into that
environment it's weird for for me too
and then that's a place where I also
thought I need to wear nails I need
Japan and all of this thing but then I
think I felt so much love going to
places in downtown
and what you're doing is valid that
that's why I'm comfortable enough to
walk around in any venue and it's
divided in sections absolutely I will
not say it's not but I think there's a
spot for everybody in all these areas I
like the way I look outside of drag
three-two-one
[ __ ] I'm hot out of drag gotta love
yourself first then you love the crap
I feel very thankful to be happy with
the way I look outside of drag because I
think there are a lot of people that
don't I know a couple of friends who
have told me that they do drag because
it makes them feel more confident with
their appearances because outside of
drag they feel ugly and they feel like a
nobody I used to really [ __ ] hate the
way I looked I was a short skinny kid
and I was fam I was the worst of
everything you could possibly be growing
up Catholic Mexican in the south you
know through drag I was able to find the
things I loved about myself and kind of
feed that until I got to a point where I
really don't give a [ __ ] anymore I love
the way I look I [ __ ] love it I don't
know if I would have got in there
without the drag I mean I love the way I
look at a drag like I'm a big guy which
is harder to be a gay man who is larger
I can go to West Hollywood and drag and
sit VIP at pump or sir if I go as a boy
I gotta check my ID pay what maybe
double the cover you know no one's gonna
buy me a drink I gotta buy the doorman a
drink like it's like that so I love
myself out of drag I just need y'all to
love me up out a drag you can find me
I've seen all of you outside of Dragon
it's a very distinct looks and I like
y'all outside of drag I don't know if
that counts for anything cuz it's your
opinion but listen I live for y'all
outside of Dragon I'm glad y'all hey
guys thank you so much for watching this
episode tell us your favorite moment
from this video favorite who do you
relate to the mo and what expectations
were shattered and what judgements were
thrown at the window follow us on
Instagram we have some more content for
you there and thank you as always for
letting us make things that explore the
spectrum of humanity in all types of
ways we'll see you next time